في مقعد الراكب الخلفي في
السيارة الغارقة كان هناك طفل يبلغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات
محاصرًا في مقعد سيارته، شعرت وكأنني
أموت ليس من أجلي كثيرًا ولكن من أجل
الطفل الذي عشته قليلاً لكنه كان قد
بلغ للتو الثالثة من عمره وهو
أب أورلاندو  يقول بارون إنه فقد
السيطرة على سيارته أثناء محاولته تجنب
سيارة قادمة ثم اصطدم
بقناة حتى عندما وصلت الشرطة، رفض
ترك بجانب ابنه، وهذا ما
رأيته عندما وصلت إلى هناك، كان الأب
يحاول الإمساك بطفله  قائلًا إنه
لا يستطيع إخراج الطفل من الماء
استجاب ضباط شرطة ميامي ديد إلى
مكان الحادث، حيث غاص الضابط إيمانويل والتون
على الفور في المياه العكرة
عدة مرات في كل مرة يخرج
خالي الوفاض في كل مرة
يخرج فيها بالفعل ولن يفعل ذلك.  عندما
خرجت مع الطفل، فقد أثار قلقنا
بعد دقائق، تمكن الضابط والتون بطريقة ما من
تحديد موقع الصبي وتحريره، وفي النهاية
شعرت بالطفل يجلس في مقعد السيارة
وسحبته بأقصى ما أستطيع
لأنني لم أتمكن من معرفة مكان
حزام الأمان.  أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل،
لحسن الحظ، انقطع وتمكن الطفل من
الصعود إلى أعلى السيارة،
وكان إخراج كريستوفر الصغير من مقعد سيارته نصف التحدي فقط
بعد الإحساس الثالث بالإنعاش القلبي الرئوي، حيث
قذف الماء الذي كان  داخل
معدته حسنًا، يقول الضابط الصغير جونيور
كليرفيل إنه فكر في ابنه وهو
يحاول الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي مرارًا وتكرارًا من الناحية
العاطفية، كان هذا أسوأ يوم في
حياتي ولكنه أيضًا أفضل يوم في حياتي، هؤلاء
الضباط، وجميعهم آباء، يشيدون
بعملهم الجماعي  للتغلب على
الصعاب في قناة حيث رأوا معظم
ضحايا الحوادث يفقدون حياتهم، نحن جميعًا
آباء في
ذلك اليوم، استجابوا للمكالمة
إذا كان ذلك ملكهم أتذكر عندما
كنت ذاهبًا إلى المستشفى مع الطفل الذي
تركته  تركت حزام البندقية، كنت
في الجزء الخلفي من سيارة الإسعاف
كمدني عادي، لم يكن الأمر يتعلق حقًا
بأداء وظيفتي، بل كان يتعلق أكثر كما تعلم
سبعة في اليوم، لقد شعرت وكأنني إنسان أكثر من
إنسان أكثر
ضابط شرطة بصراحة